ils sont taxis indépendants ambulanciers
et ils sont très inquiet pour l'avenir
de leur profession car désormais ce sont
les hôpitaux qui vont gérer les
transports sanitaires en passant des
appels d'offres un système d'attribution
de marchés qui favorisera les grands
groupes au détriment des petites
entreprises les grands groupes ils ont
les reins solides donc ils ont plus de
facilité de travailler pendant une année
ou deux années à perte et après une fois
que nous on se sera essoufflé qu on
n'existera plus par contre eux ils
pourront pratiquer les tarifs qu'ils
auront envie de pratiquer aussi aux
rangs plus personne derrière lui
conséquence les passions pourrait bien
faire les frais de ce changement afin de
serrer les prix des transports
sanitaires
la priorité pourrait être donnée à des
trajets groupé vers les établissements
hospitaliers et retour à domicile le
jour où ça va être un transporteur
lambda qui vont mettre des petites
voitures avec marc et taxibus dessus et
on leur dira monsieur vous n'avez pas le
choix c'est soit ils vous emmènent ont
fait un tour de u2 enfin détour de 10 15
km pour en prendre quatre ou cinq
ils n'auront pas le choix c'est soit il
montre en dedans ou après froid qui se
débrouillent tout seuls pour les
serveurs traitement à dijon on suivait
attentivement ce matin le blocage du
périphérique parisien par les
ambulanciers ceux de l'yonne sont
nombreux à avoir rejoint la
manifestation dans la capitale
car dans ce département comme dans le
châtillonnais les petites structures de
transport sanitaire qui assurent le
maillage des territoires ruraux se
sentent menacés on permet en fait aux
patients qui sont très éloignées des
centres de soins de s'y rendre et de
pouvoir bénéficier de leur traitement
si aujourd'hui on ne peut plus effectuer
notre travail dans les mêmes conditions
et remplir en fait notre service donc
tous ces gens là devront supporter
probablement un service hub et reese et
une pétition a été lancée elle circule
également sur internet
elle incite les usagers à dénoncer eux
aussi l'article 81 du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale déjà
en vigueur depuis le 1er octobre